[Music]
a quick look at the clock means it is
time for the press preview our first
look at the front pages as they arrive
over the remainder of their we'll take a
look at what's making the headlines with
the journalist and author rachel shabby
and the daily telegraph's leader writer
tim stanley to them in just a second but
let's take a look at the front pages
in our inbox ah well with the headline
britain
steps up to lead the world the express
welcomes a deal struck
by the leading global economies to
ensure corporations are made to prepare
they
pay their fair share of tax
here's the mirror it reports that the
labour party is demanding that the
government use the money from the tax
deal
to fund hospitals and schools the
telegraph has word of plans
it has word that plans are underway to
vaccinate 12 to 15 year olds in august
that is of course just before the start
of the new school year
meanwhile the observer understands that
the pm is being lobbied to share more of
the uk's vaccine supply with developing
nations or else
it may not be possible to reach the
landmark deal on climate change
expected at the g7 summit in cornwall
here's scotland on sunday it reports on
concerns in the hospitality sector that
the go-ahead for fan zones in glasgow
for euro 2020
presents a substantial risk for the
spreading of kovitz this could mean
foods and drink vendors not turning a
profit
out let's stick with scottish matters
and according to the times buckingham
palace plans to have the duke and
duchess of cambridge
spend a great deal of time north of the
border to shore up support
for staying in the union the mail
reports that the home secretary has
ordered social media giants
to remove posts that glamorize illegal
channel crossing
and the star hears that the actor john
barrowman has withdrawn from
pantomime after reports emerged that
he'd exposed himself on the set of
doctor who and torchwood he has of
course insisted the incidents took place
as part of practical jokes
i might just skip over that story
tonight uh we are joined as you can see
by rachel shabby
and tim stanley lovely to see you both
this evening and
and we're going to devote you know all
our time in this this particular quarter
to to
what is being described as a very big
story tim take us to the front of the
sunday expression
and explain exactly why rishi sunak you
can just see the bottom left of the
screen
is looking so pleased with himself this
is a very big
moment in the economic history of the
world and britain is going to claim
leadership for us the tories are going
to say
people said what would britain be like
after brexit well this is what it's like
tackling tax evasion what is the big
issue that
this has addressed it is that
multinationals
can do the vast majority of their
business in one country and make a lot
of
money out of doing that because they are
resident in another country with a very
very low
tax rate uh they can escape paying the
amount of tax they really ought to pay
disproportionate to the amount of
business
they've done in the amount of profit
they've made in other words they're
getting away
without paying a fair share of tax and
what britain is claiming
credit for here is bring the g7 together
to coordinate the
agreement to levy a minimum tax
of 15 corporation tax which means
that wherever you do business that is
the amount of tax that you must
pay now to get the leading economies of
the world to agree that
to agree to what is essentially a form
of tax harmonization
admittedly which sets the bar quite low
joe biden wanted the figure to be
something more like 21
but they settled on 15 this is a very
real accomplishment
and it deals as i said with this problem
of how do you tax the new industries
how do you get around the challenge of
tax evasion and britain
is going to spend the next few days
claiming leadership on it
um rachel it would it'd be easy to be
quite cynical about this given that this
problem has existed since what in my
mind since time immemorial and there has
been
efforts to try and to try and fix it i
suppose the question is
how does one compel the rest of the
world to sign up to this we're already
hearing noises from places like
ireland of course that it might not be
entirely what they want to do
no and of course there's going to be
pushback from uh particularly from
countries who do operate currently low
tax havens in ireland would be one of
those um but
we also have to observe that it is a bit
peculiar that the uk is claiming
the credit for this uh the uk was
actually um
you know caught somewhat by surprise to
the extent that they wanted
um climate change issues to be on the
agenda i believe that was uh what rishi
sunak
was planning to discuss in these uh
negotiations that were
joe biden and u.s lead
and it was actually the uk that was one
of the countries that
drove the rate down
from uh biden's initial proposal of 21
now many critics of this policy are
saying
15 simply isn't enough plus
the way that this is structured will
mean that it actually
predominantly benefits g7 countries at
the expense of developing countries
but i think that those serious concerns
notwithstanding this is a huge thing
um to have a globally agreed
attempt to mitigate the worst successes
of multinationals tax avoidance who
as you say this has been going on for
decades it's got worse and worse with
tech giants in particular
being identified as the most sort of
aggressive
pursuers of tax avoidance so we're
looking at companies like google
facebook michael's microsoft amazon
netflix companies it has to be said
whose profits have skyrocketed
during the pandemic and so you know this
idea that the world is no longer
engaging in a sort of race to the bottom
in terms of low corporation tax i do
think that is something to be herald
welcomed um tim as we as we bring in the
the front of the observer and again can
a similar reporting uh by them they're
describing it
as a as a landmark deal as well i i mean
ultimately we've heard this evening that
at least a couple of the major tech
firms are
are relatively sanguine they say that
they welcome this do you think that's
do you think that's the situation or
have they just read the writing and all
i think they've read the writing on the
wall and it's it's
it's proof of what power uh democracies
enjoy when they club together and work
together multinationally by the way in
the beginning uh in my first answer i
it's been a bit it's a bit late and i
referred to tax evasion i should have
said tax avoidance my apologies they are
two different things
what's changed to change the dimension
to change the dynamic of this is joe
biden's election
uh here the two g7s for the last few g7s
have not been terribly productive
and that's because donald trump was
leading the united states and whether
you agree with his agenda or not his
agenda was america first
in other words he see he saw global
relations
through the prism of national
competition
for him others describe that as a race
the bottom what do i have to do to set
tax rates at a certain level
and to set spending at a certain level
whereby i can make america the front
runner
joe biden has a completely different
economic philosophy
he is spending big at home he's keen to
raise certain taxes
and he also wants to work together with
developing countries to make the
forums like the g7 productive again in
order to get
things which have been delayed for the
last few years not just
the issue of tax avoidance but also
climate change
to get those things addressed so really
although britain will claim
leadership here in it and it certainly
helps that the g7 will be having its
meeting next week in cornwall so that's
a very good stage for britain
uh to strut about on what's really
changed the dynamic
is u.s leadership and and it is for many
of us ironic who have been following
american politics for some time to see
particularly janet yellen's role in all
of this because
she was so cautious under the obama
presidency
about um about interest rates and about
spending
she was seen as somewhat fiscally
conservative and now she's on the other
side of the argument
and most central banks are moving
towards the other side of the argument
they are embracing printing money
they are encouraging governments to
spend more
although we've been through these twin
revolutions of trump and brexit which
give the impression
that world politics and economics has
moved to the right
it couldn't be further from the truth
there is still a globalist consensus
there is still a multilateral consensus
and actually in the last few months
partly because of the context of covid
it's getting a lot done um rachel we'll
we'll go to the front of the telegraph
and again
similar reporting there but an
interesting nugget further down in the
piece
pointing out that of course mr sunak
himself had actually before entering
government
cited reduced rates of corporation tax
is one of a reason one of a series of
possible incentives for
for businesses choosing uh to to operate
within the the freeport system i mean
does does it matter that there is a
slight divergence
from mr sunac's previous position we
always understand that people's politics
change
and of course the global situation has
dramatically changed since the point
that he was
outside government i don't think it
would
matter had it not been that
sunac and the government is now crowing
about
leading this breakthrough deal which is
what's happening
so you know rishi sunak is of course
free to change his mind and to evolve
his position as we all do
but for him to now say well this is
amazing and for the government to say
this is
you know for the express to say this is
what you know post-brexit
britain looks like it's absolutely
absurd given
that this is not where they are in terms
of uh corporate tax it certainly
interferes with the free ports policy
as the telegraph uh is describing and
crucially it wasn't them that led this
it was joe biden it was the us as tim as
tim is saying that is
the major shift um in all this
and you know it is true that joe biden
has changed his approach to
economics he's you know recently spoken
about it being the
end of you know trickle down economics
that it's not
a thing that it doesn't work it does
seem like even joe biden who
you know i would not define as
particularly left-wing in fact
if anything he's you know a centrist
moderate i think he's just
seen the reality that we are in
and that reality is one of you know
spending of government spend of
keynesian economics
and of actually calling out that
trickle-down economics does not work
and has produced the world's most
rampant inequalities
uh of course of course tim i mean we
could we could equally say the
conservatives on this side of the pond
have
have looked at their economic policies
in the past and have decided to go in a
slightly different direction but as we
take a look at the sunday mirror
perhaps the least surprising exclusive
of the weekend is that the labour
party's
suggesting that the dividend that we
will receive from this should be spent
on
on the health service and on education
yes and the tories will come under
pressure to do both those things they're
also keen to spend on infrastructure
in fact apart from foreign aid the
conservative party seems keen to spend
on most things
and that that's the other side of this
there is a philosophical shift that's
taking place
in some ways there's continuity david
cameron was very keen on tackling tax
avoidance too
and tax evasion too david cameron was
also very keen on tackling climate
change but the
there's a big iron in the heart of all
of this that brexit was very much pushed
by the thatcherite wing of the
conservative party
who always imagined that the point of
brexit was that after it
you would slash regulations and slash
taxes and probably
cut spending and turn britain into some
dynamic free market buccaneering economy
like they imagined singapore is it looks
like we're going to get the complete
opposite
that after brexit partly to keep hold of
the working-class voters that boris has
won over there's going to be
more spending there's this shift towards
global tax harmonization which by the
way
undermines british sovereignty no you
can't do free ports or have northern
ireland set a
a really low corporation tax rate if you
sign up this sort of thing
plus we're also seeing britain on board
with the climate change agenda
in other words the conservative party in
order to win
a majority and in order to stay in power
has moved
to the left and the right of the tory
party who are the geniuses behind brexit
have got to ask themselves how did we
end up here
how did we end up with boris the
classical liberal doing this
with the conservative party
unfortunately we have to take a break
otherwise and i've really
really enjoyed hearing from both of you
as to exactly how we got to that
particular position uh guys we will take
a pause for just a second
uh coming up after the break is a charm
offensive
from the duke and duchess of cambridge
the secret to keeping scotland in the
union
hmm we'll ponder that next
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview tim
and rachel still with us and rachel
we'll come to you in just a second i
want to give our viewers
two kind of not unrelated stories at the
first on the front of the observer the
headline there
uh share vaccines or the climate deal
will fail which countries are being told
the uk presumably included within that
and then the front of the telegraph the
sunday telegraph uh which is also
talking
um about the about vaccines but in terms
of the the plan to jab
12 year olds before the new school year
we're in a situation at the moment
rachel where the the vaccination program
is going
pretty well but everyone in this country
wants to see life returning to normal
just as soon as possible
how much moral pressure do you think
there is
or and indeed should be on the
politicians to share the stocks that we
have
given the most vulnerable in this
country have have gen generally had both
their vaccines
i do think that the unequal global
distribution
of vaccines is a real failure
it's a real like as a as a civilization
as a humanity you know humanity has
failed when you look at the stats you
know the two billion
shots that have gone into people's arms
only 0.3
of those um are in low-income countries
and i find it peculiar the sort of
things that are being applied as
pressure points i i
you know the climate deal will fail if
um
developing countries aren't given more
vaccines well
first of all i think that's a peculiar
peculiar reading this is apparently what
boris johnson has been advised you know
developing crunches are the ones that
are driving the pressure
to address climate change not least
because they're the countries that
are you know the most suffering from the
effects of climate change which has been
caused mostly by developed by developed
countries but it's interesting that
that's being applied as a pressure point
um also the idea that you know
we all the world needs to get vaccinated
so that all of us can be safe you know
i.e variants
will emerge in other countries
if the vaccines aren't applied globally
um so these are sort of seem like
self-interested reasons as opposed to
just saying
look it's just the right thing to do to
make sure
that the entire world is vaccinated in
an equal pace
and i think that this whole idea of
getting countries
rich countries to stop hoarding vaccines
and stop buying them up and actually
share them more equally is is absolutely
the right thing to do but it gets away
from the main issue here which is
patents
so the uk a lot of you and other
countries are blocking
requests from the developing world 100
plus countries
to waive the patents on vaccines so that
they can be produced
and distributed nationally that's
something that needs to change
immediately tim i just want to squeeze
in the story we'll return to both of
these in fact in the 11 o'clock hour but
i just want to squeeze in the story on
the front of the sunday times that we
teased that the palace is sending for
prince william to rescue the union
what's your
thought what are your thoughts is he the
man for the job
it's really interesting to see the royal
family thinking that it has to take a
much more visible role
in the next referendum if there is one
uh during the last one the queen
limited herself to saying that she hoped
people would think carefully about the
future
and of course you could read that any
either way you could think carefully
about the future and
and say and i've decided the best thing
to do is to vote for independence so
it was a very carefully couched
expression this is different this
suggests that
the royal family want to be more
involved in the political decision that
they see
affecting them because it's a
constitutional decision
so it doesn't entirely surprise me will
it work they're
they're very popular and they're
certainly more popular than politicians
and they are tempted it's going to be
difficult that wouldn't be difficult
sorry to interrupt rachel a very quick
word on this i mean he is
more popular 69 percent of voters in
scotland have a positive view
of william apparently you're absolutely
right
and it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
difficult to get a more a positive
rating than politicians particularly
boris johnson who polls very
low in scotland but i just i just think
yeah people might like the royalty
the royal family in scotland maybe but
that doesn't
you know i don't think that's really
going to cut it
and it seems a little bit desperate to
me
as i say guys we will return to both
those stories in the 11 o'clock for now
though thanks very much indeed
time for us to have a look at the
weather